couple things today number one it is the
anniversary of
paul walker dying so uh f in the chat
f in the chat for worse keanu reeves and
uh also today is cyber monday which
means
um absolutely nothing because all the
black friday deals on amazon were
[ __ ] trash
and all of the cyber monday deals on
amazon i haven't looked yet but i'm
assuming are trash right
and on top of all that i haven't been
able to get a hold of one of the new
xboxes or a ps5
i've haven't really tried that hard but
i want one
you know probably both i'm probably
trying to try to get both but
um i haven't had i just haven't had the
the luck as it were yeah capitalism day
you can't give amazon all your money and
i say that but
as somebody who just bought stuff on
amazon i'm gonna keep using it and
i understand the hypocrisy i am fully
aware that i hate jeff bezos
and i know amazon's taking over the
world but
also it's so easy it's it's what am i
gonna do get in my car and go to a local
store and pay [ __ ] fifty dollars more
for the same thing
okay okay boomer i'm gonna do that i'm
bringing okay boomer back by the way for
those people that don't know
i kind of feel like that didn't last
long enough so i'm bringing it back
yes i understand amazon's destroying
this country but exactly broham but
two-day shipping though
sorry two-day shipping it's gonna happen
what's better a ps5 or a deep fried
turkey a deep-fried ps5
it's the best way to do it
jesus i just bought an xbox 360. you're
a little behind hobo buddy
local retail stores ha ha local retail
stores have
anything of quality anymore look at fry
there's no i i know of fries because
i've been to states that haven't there's
no fries here though there's no fries in
florida
yeah exactly j dubs you're right i'm
gonna put my shoes and socks on
like a [ __ ] pleb and go to the mall
okay cool i'm gonna just i'm just gonna
put my
[ __ ] shoes on all right i'm gonna
just
oh look at me putting my shoes on like
[ __ ]
mr rogers and i'm gonna go to a mall
i'm gonna go to the new minority [ __ ]
nightclub
the mall okay sure i'll do that you're
right
why don't i just go to a locally owned
restaurant while i'm at it
look at these [ __ ] losers you [ __ ]
hipsters
oh i'm gonna put a light jacket on
because it's
chilly and go park in a parking spot
and enter the store through the macy's
that way i remember where i park
so i could walk through a mall
no thank you
[ __ ] look at this guy with a mall
jesus you'd be people you people sicken
me
there's people dying and you're going to
a mall there's people
dying in the [ __ ] i was walking over
people on the streets as i went to get
my mail
i had to walk over dead bodies and look
at this people like oh
go to the mall support local businesses
okay
sure i'll do that fine if you want
grandma to die
not me
not me all right
let some glorified uber driver deliver
to my door in two days
thank you very much thank you
very much you're welcome
that's a really good point beef drew
what am i gonna do i'm gonna go to a
mall i'll go to a hot topic and buy a
[ __ ] night
[ __ ] nightmare before christmas shirt
oh cool yeah i'm gonna go screw
wanna go to spencer's gift and buy a
dildo pen oh yeah all right i'm just
gonna do that
i'm just gonna because i have time i
have plenty of time to go to a mall
ugh you people are [ __ ] gross you are
gross people
going to malls and wasting your times
all right
i instead will go to amazon and have the
recommended algorithm tell me what i
need to buy for my family and friends
and spoiler alert it's usually a product
that's made by amazon
i mean statistically that's what i see
it's usually a product that's made by
amazon
so let's not let's not get into it all
right
imagine going home oh oh my god
imagine having a imagine having to
remember where you
parked
cool boy's right there you go to sharper
image and use their massage chair they
don't really kick you out they
pretty much leave you alone let's go to
sharp ribbons under their massager for a
few hours i mean unless there's like
unless there's a lot of people you could
sit there for a while
go to the dead mall on international
drive the only one
that has a ron john store still which
one's that one
you mean the outdoor mall nick that one
i think i know what you're talking i
think i know which one you're talking
about
oh yeah the one in the i know which
exactly which one you're talking about
yeah that thing's always dead go to the
time machine stop and uh
shop and buy an old-time old-fashioned
department store that's not a bad idea
i go to the mall for haircuts oh my god
look i mean
this is by the way coming to somebody
who cuts his own hair obviously just
shave my head so it's it's not like um
it's not like it's a big deal for me
but mall haircuts
what do you go to [ __ ] hair cuttery i
ain't doing that
i'm gonna do that anyway i remember what
hair was like
it was a hassle hair was
a hassle uh yeah sure i'll go to the
mall
uh i'll go to the food court right
before i go to a movie theater and sit
down with
other people to watch the same film okay
or or i could sit at home and watch
whatever i want
ain't happening